hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video were back on apex legends and a
new trailer just dropped for season 2
battle charge and we got a lot of stuff
to talk about today so as always like
the V if you do enjoy I covered the
informational side of apex let's just to
keep everyone up to date and make sure
no one misses out on an update as well
as talking about the lore of every
character in apex legends so what that
like to be if you do enjoy it and let's
get started so right in the first couple
of seconds we see some random dude on
top of a hillside and we see him put a
chip of with a logo on it into a
computer and this is most likely going
to be the syndicate logo a company
mentioned numerous times throughout the
lore and the bios of the characters in
apex legends and and they actually have
something to do with the APUs games
themselves although it's not
specifically clear majority of it though
is just the characters killing each
other and the cinematic team and whoever
worked on this needs a raise because
this every time they do this [ __ ] is
just so pristine and perfect I love the
way to animate these trailers it's
really excellent some notable things is
that you can see an L star skin which is
likely going to be a legendary held by
Mirage as he's trying to shoot octane
and it also looks like we have a new
ability for bloodhound and I also saw
something for Watson although I'm not
even really sure that's the case though
as for this new ability I can't tell if
it's just cinematic effect or we're
actually getting something new but it
looks like a simple throwing star that
you can throw at people and then it will
explode after some time or maybe the
player can trigger at any moment I'm
assuming that's going to have to replace
his tactical ability which is the pretty
obvious one where he can see people
through walls so I have a fairly certain
idea that that's not going to be
replaced that's literally bloodhounds
whole thing and I think this is more for
a cinematic effect there was also
another one where Watson were octane
actually got crushed by a tower which
we'll get to in a second and then Watson
ended up reviving octane with her
shocked hands using them as
defibrillators once again I also think
this is cinematic effects because they
would have to get rid of her a bit one
of her abilities and her abilities are
honestly way too good for her to be
getting rid of those her fence is really
nice and her ultimate is with a nice as
well but back to that EMP the dude on
the tower activated you know put the
chip in the computer and pressed enter
on his on his little laptop and then
that activated an EMP which destroyed
all the stuff on this big Tower which
was most likely keeping the Leviathans
at bay
because once that crashed and
practically killed octane the Leviathans
and all the Flyers started coming into
the map now there's this huge giant
Leviathan in the map or everyone calls
them Turtles or the squishy boys ever
the [ __ ] everybody everybody calls these
things I call them by the real name the
Leviathans oh yeah they were on the
outskirts of the map and they slowly
started getting closer to the island but
now they're officially going to be on
the island during season two as for what
they're gonna do no idea can you grapple
to them I don't know where they're gonna
keep walking around no idea either are
they gonna be able to kill you
maybe who knows well have to see but
yeah I'm just as equally as excited as
you guys to figure out what the hell's
gonna be going on like we said in past
couple videos for season two we're gonna
be getting a lot more stuff like a new
character Watson new area maps like this
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] is going on with
this Leviathan a couple new hop ups to
make some of the shittier guns a lot
better and way way more improved battle
paths we still don't know what all 100
tiers of the battle paths are yet but
I'll sure to recover that for you guys
as well and I'm also gonna be making a
video and kind of discussing should you
come back to apex season 2 and is this
battle pass a lot better because I want
to see if I can attract a lot more older
players that kind of dropped off the
game or newer players don't want to come
in for themselves during season 2 yeah
let me know what you guys think about
this trailer like I said equally as
hyped as you guys are for this [ __ ]
especially the Leviathan I want to see
what these guys can do in the map be
elective if you do enjoy guys subscribed
for new I covered the informational side
of apex legends so if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening in the world of apex legends
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
I also cover the lore of the characters
and apex legends I did one on octane and
I also did one on the new character
Watson so you guys can go check that out
on my channel as well should be in the
endcard I believe the Watson one will
show up on the end card but that guy's
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen with that watch those and
enjoy the rest you
you